depuis plusieurs semaines nous faisons
des démarches pour nous même essayer de
voir dans quelle mesure nous pourrions
apporter des déjà comprendre la
situation et apporter des solutions et
ce qui fait que aujourd'hui sachant que
le conseil d'état venait viendra nous
voir sur le paul il était normal que
finalement les personnes qui nous
soutiennent sur le fait que nous ne
voulons pas de scission au niveau de
l'établissement et que nous sommes pour
une université des antilles puisse aussi
nous accompagner puisque nous savons
qu'un certain nombre de deux personnes
notamment sur la gouvernance polaire
avec des élus de martinique souhaitent
aller vers une scission serait
aujourd'hui
alors c'est vrai qu'on ne confonde donc
pas très bien pourquoi ils sont sur
cette position
à part pour des des idées très
politiques ou personnelles et sachant
que ça devient très compliqué pour un
établissement de devoir perdre en fait
entre guillemets ses amis donc si nous
devons partir vers une scission on
deviendrait une petite université et
encore avec 3000 étudiants voire
peut-être un peu moins et donc ce n'est
pas envisageable d'autant que je vous
rappelle quand même que l'université des
antilles à l'époque s'appelait
université antilles et de la guyane
donc nous avons déjà perdu un élément et
perdre encore un autre élève ans ce
n'est pas envisageable d'autant que nous
voulons qu'il y ait une dynamique sur ce
campus et de façon globale au sein de
l'établissement de notre université et
donc nous souhaitons un développement de
la recherche avec des coopérations aussi
bien interne que régional donc oil
boucle un cynique